[音楽]
この動画は
私が実際に体験した実話に基づいた動画です
うん
me
いい天気だなぁ
[音楽]
春だね春
あじーさん
goods さん
いつからでしょうか
この
夏ら15という男
数唱ゴッチさんということが号
気づいたら
私の家に
でーじす中になっていたのです
[音楽]
いつからか覚えていませんが
彼は私のお手伝いをしたいと言い
[音楽]
私の家だ
5最近
ずーっと居座っているんですよ皆さん
ですかーっていうのなら長い時間一緒にいることによって
気づいたことがあるのです
この男
enter
これはある日
外での撮影がアスタに控えた日の話ですたんっはいまた明日外の撮影なんですけど
ちょっと長い撮影になりそうなんでこれちょっとバッテリー充電しておきます
これバッテリーばせず持ってきてくださいこれやばいですくださいはい
忘れちゃだめだよはいうんねぇー
ええええええ
[音楽]
翌日
我々は山奥の撮影場所に3人で移動し
動画の撮影をしようとしていました
なぜかかれば張り切った様子で撮影場所に向かっていました
を押し
じゃあここらへんだと言いますかはいっ
決定性がこの時すでに
事件は起きていたのですね
me
[音楽]
待ってるよされました
かお子さん
そういえばうち最近700万なかったじゃないですかはい
あれちょっとマジで盗まれたらやばいんで防犯ちょっと気をつけましょうか
妖怪ます鍵つの井戸でちゃんとかけてくださいホンダですねはいとじ針お願いしますよ
はいとヤバイんでございます
彼にはしっかりと書をかけるようにとって自然入り人放っておいたのですか
この2時間後
を縛りと終え彼が帰るとキッズしまうね普段はちゃんと鍵をかけるのですがなぜか
この時に限ってい
そのまま帰ってしまったのです
ん
直径ず見てもの切るまずいかついカップ java いっしょ度一緒に学校呼びデ
サイナーまあバイザーんねこれあれしょんだねければのマーベルネイル走前ビールが
よく知らないんだけどねマーベルのヒーローめっちゃ書いてろさてねー
そのスーツはビブラに運勢の先生できるんですけど
teacher 感を着て手で映画だと着る者が後とかですけど
1結構人気が出てって今度2今公開予定年住んでい
もともとブラックパンサー自体がシビル頃から出てきて
そのキャロになってください
さっき言っただけはねめっちゃ気に入ってるんだこれやん数やばいよね
普通にのからくれそうだった口なんで知らないんだからねこれ
だけどねぇこいつだけよくわかんないんだよね私見学他の結構有名な感じのやつ来て
ですねそのこいつホって何かわかんなくては猿 gekko 5
これはミドル抹茶ですねっとバッグ誰
今からレアアバカンですよくわからない風邪なんか感じで置き捨て
ロキはバイティーソーの弟って設定 s とマイティーソー持っているムジョルニア魂
があるです
からけてくらあなんでうち月んですよなってこのアイロン
[音楽]
私が家の外に出かけるときやしなくなるときはみんなも外に出るようにしています
あんことはそうそう変えてくださいはいライスと老荘出るであーやばいです
ここ家から外に出るように催促したの犠牲がその30分
彼は何も変わらず
私の家にいたのです
武さん
こさん
ブザーん
5さーんんっ
こちゃーん
んん
[音楽]
はっはっは
あーカレー食いてぇ足ですねー
分
お試しいけません昨日ねっ
うん
誰か言ってませんよ you see
妹友
あっここ右ですね左すね右 sb です
やばくていますし
マイすぎデー
いっぎゅうーっと
いっ
rai たい
ana 会いたい
なかったんでだ
[音楽]
bale
bai
寺なんだよ
[音楽]
んでーない
me
寝ないばねぇ
ああああああ
aname
me
[音楽]
数え方にありがとう
ずっとーう
馬場の値段
ちょっと待ってやばいやばいすごいやるよ終わってください理由ん
[音楽]
ん
ここロッドのを作った
鈴江です5番やなぁんもう2の報酬だし避けてくださいですようん
普通なパセリがふざけた方ですん
だ2つん
セブ最近700万円残ったぜっ立っこりゃジャンプし